my name is anna kate hicks and i'm a
freshman
from cincinnati ohio it is my pleasure
this afternoon to introduce our speaker
richard b gunderman is chancellor's
professor of radiology
pediatrics medical education philosophy
liberal arts philanthropy and medical
humanities and health studies
at indiana university where he's also
the
john a campbell professor of radiology
he also serves as bicentennial professor
at indiana university
and as president of the medical staff
executive at iu health
he received his a b from wabash college
and his md
and phd from the university of chicago
he is a 10 time recipient
of the indiana university trustees
teaching award
and in 2012 he received the gloucester
teaching award
from the association of american medical
colleges
dr gunderman is the author of numerous
articles
and 15 books including we make a life by
what we give
tesla contagion and marie curie
please help me in welcoming dr
gunderberg
[Applause]
good afternoon it's a treat to be here
um i didn't know what i was doing when i
applied to college but i stumbled into a
very good
all-male liberal arts college in
northwest central indiana called wabash
college actually an all-male
institution was which was not an
enticement to me
but i had a chance to get to meet
terrific faculty members
who opened up intellectual horizons
and professional opportunities that i
don't think
would have even occurred to me let alone
seemed feasible
and then as ak indicated thanks to them
i ended up at the university of chicago
pursued fairly conventional medical
studies
but was in a program called the medical
scientist training program
and got to study in the committee on
social thought
so i went to an undergraduate liberal
arts institution
and if you read the description of the
committee on social thought at the
university of chicago at least at the
time
i was there it described itself as among
other things providing a liberal
education
at the graduate level so i'm a person
who's had the opportunity to pursue
liberal arts education for a long time
at a few institutions and i'm delighted
to bring some of that learning today
to this talk which is on the importance
of the liberal arts
but we'll be focusing on a physician's
view
would a physician have anything useful
to say about the liberal arts
and equally interesting does the liberal
arts
have anything to contribute to medicine
so uh let me start out by correcting
what could be a misapprehension
that might flow from the title of this
presentation
in my view the liberal arts aren't
really separable from medicine
nor are the liberal arts preparation for
medicine
in fact the liberal arts and medicine
are largely
co-extensive they would overlap a lot on
a venn diagram
at least if we see them clearly
thrive as a reader or a teacher
or a writer of books one must attend to
many of the same
things that command a physician's
attention to care well
for patients requires the same
habits of ear mind and heart
that the liberal arts aim to cultivate
in both spheres it takes years perhaps
decades perhaps even a lifetime
to learn to perceive understand
and respond with compassion and
imagination
to the human reality before us
both spheres require the cultivation of
essentially
the same human excellences
consider a story shared with me by one
of my favorite medical students
whose name is muhammad
muhammad left the hospital one
dank winter night and as he walked to
his bicycle
he saw a large mountain of a man
carrying three bags approaching him
on the sidewalk the man's intentions
were unclear
did he for example plan to ask for money
did he intend to take it by force
but muhammad resisted the temptation
to cross to the other side
the distance between them soon closed
and soon the man's chest was just
inches from muhammad's face
the man said do you work here
i need to get to the emergency room
muhammad replied it's a few blocks away
the man asked could you drive me there
actually said muhammad i rode my bike
today
the man took off his backpack opened it
and handed muhammad a blanket
he said here take this it's too cold to
be out biking
then the man said please don't leave me
here alone
i'm blind if you want to learn
teach or write about the importance of
not
jumping to conclusions not writing
people off
based on how they look or talk
or even smell you could do worse
than to read a letter the greatest
physician poet in the english language
john keats wrote on a dank winter night
in 1817
to his brothers george and tom
considering the close relationship of
truth and beauty
in king lear keats describes what he
calls
negative capability
negative capability the ability to be
in uncertainties mysteries
and doubts without any irritable
reaching
after fact and reason
when we encounter something we're not
sure about
an idea a new way of thinking
a large mountain of a man
carrying three bags keats
counsels us to observe to be
patient to dwell in uncertainty
and to avoid resorting to predetermined
categories
his counsel to patience shines all the
more brightly
when we consider that keats himself
died of tuberculosis at the age of only
25 years
keats is like socrates
if we explain every new thing we
encounter
in terms of what we already know
will never learn anything new
we'll keep explaining everything as
a or b a or not a
and never recognize that there's also a
c
a d and an e
socrates was likened by his
contemporaries to a torpedo
fish or a stingray
which jolts its prey disorienting it
in the dialogues of plato mino
wants to enrich his cocktail party
repertoire
by quoting socrates accounts
of the virtues simeous and seabees
want to know why a person should keep
striving to be
good even though death
comes to the virtuous and vicious alike
but before they can gain real insight
socrates
interlocutors must first set aside
at least for a time what they think they
know
if they're going to gain new insight
they must first admit
that they do not know then they can cast
off anew
in the pursuit of wisdom they must drink
liberally from that most ironic of
wellsprings
negative capability
reviewing video recordings of hundreds
of physician patient encounters
a colleague of mine determined
that we physicians can listen to
patients
for how many seconds until we interrupt
the answer is 18.
we that is physicians
in the words of sergeant joe friday
we want just the facts that is just the
parts of the story
that fit neatly into our preconceptions
and we wanted them to be conveyed as
efficiently as possible
how easily we forget that the patient
is sharing with us more than the clues
to a diagnosis the patient is sharing a
human experience
one that deserves to be treated as more
than a mere means to an end
paraphrasing kant
we must never resolve to treat
any story as a means to confirming our
own
preconceptions only
but always at the same time
as a source of illumination in itself
what we need whether taking a history
from a patient
or reading one of keats's odes
or plato's dialogues what we need is the
capacity to listen patiently
to hear what is being said and to allow
the story itself to tell us what it
means
rather than making the story tell us
what we
expect or want to hear
consider another story this one shared
with me by a priest
whose name i can no longer recall
as part of his clinical pastoral
education
he was assigned to make monthly home
visits to a patient named
shirley shirley was an elderly woman who
lived alone
at every visit shirley would talk
virtually non-stop and her visitor
soon realized he couldn't get in a word
edgewise
feeling that he was not contributing
anything the priest
began to dread his visits with shirley
she did all the talking and he felt
useless
almost as soon as he sat down he found
himself looking for opportunities
to say that he needed to go
some time later after shirley died
the priest received a letter from his
supervisor
in which shirley went on at length
about how much his visits had meant to
her
the priest thought he was doing nothing
but by being there and listening to
shirley
he was providing exactly what she needed
in this the priest is recalling a lesson
of the greatest physician dramatist
in world literature anton
chekhov chekhov practiced medicine
all his adult life right up to his
premature death
from tuberculosis at the age of 44 years
in his short story yearning
we are treated to a ringside seat on
human loneliness
a poor cab man a taxi driver we might
say
named iona tries to share with his fares
what is weighing heavily on his heart
his son who should have succeeded him
has recently died of a febrile illness
leaving the old man all alone
first iona reaches out to a military
officer
intent on reaching his destination as
efficiently as possible
then he reaches out to a group of three
drunken young men
looking for a good time then he reaches
out to a fellow cab man
and finally he's left with his own mayor
who seems to listen as she munches on
hay
he says to her now suppose you had a
little cult
and suppose that little colt all at once
went and died you'd be sorry
wouldn't you
the practice of medicine like the study
of great literature
reminds us that sometimes what we human
beings most need
is someone to listen someone just to be
there
recall the book of job job the greatest
man in all the east
righteous and upright before god has
lost
everything his property his children
his own health he's fallen as far as a
human being can possibly descend
and he sits in ashes scratching himself
with pot shards when his three friends
eliphaz bildad and zofar
arrive on the scene they resist the
temptation
to launch into sophisticated
philosophical
and theological explanations or
justifications for what is befallen job
they simply sit down silently at their
friend's side
remaining there for seven days and seven
nights
to be sure they will later stray from
this path
but their first impulse is their best
simply to be there
we can't fix poverty ignorance
injustice or terminal illness
we certainly cannot fix mortality
but we can recognize our part
and play it well not the part of the
immortal
and ageless gods whose lives and homer
sometimes resemble nothing more than
daytime television drama
but the human part the part of achilles
and priam and hector
whose only hope for coming to life lies
in recognition
of their shared humanity achilles must
see his father
in priam and priam must see his son
in achilles achilles must see himself
in hector and hector must see himself
loaded up in battle gear through the
eyes of his terrified
son it is our capacity to be
there in the sense of occupying someone
else's space
inhabiting their reality
that constitutes one of humanity's
saving graces when we see through the
eyes of another
we gain a more complete vision of the
human
situation like many
academic hospitals and health systems in
indianapolis we have a program
called no one dies alone
its purpose is not to sustain a failing
pulse
or respiration for as long as possible
but to recognize the inevitability
and even the appropriateness of
dying and trying to enable people
to die as well as possible there are
good deaths and bad deaths
and often one of the physician's most
urgent missions
is to recognize and respect this
difference
and work on behalf of patient and family
to midwife a good death
this means addressing one of the most
common fears
i encounter with patients about dying
dying alone volunteers simply sit by the
bedside of dying patients
sometimes they hear nothing but agonal
respirations
but other times they hear stories
and sometimes the stories are rather
like those
of chekhov's cab man
when they listen with eyes and ears and
heart open
they are granted the opportunity to
answer
the human call
consider another story this would shared
with me
by the daughter of a man deceased long
ago
in the first half of the 20th century
otis
bowen md grew up the son of a teacher
in northwest indiana otis bowen's father
had eight grades of students
in a one-room school where he functioned
as teacher
janitor and nurse carrying wood and
water
to the schoolhouse and earning 2.50
cents a day
bowen decided to follow a different path
and become a physician
to get money for college and medical
school
he hoed potatoes for 10 cents
an hour he milked a cow
morning and night for 10 cents a day
he mowed grass for 25 cents
a yard 35 cents for large yards
and he shocked oats and wheat for a
dollar a day
bowen persevered eventually graduating
from the indiana university school of
medicine
serving in the pacific theater in world
war
ii setting up his own practice
in rural indiana delivering
3 000 babies over the course of his
career
including five generations in one family
and attending all of his patients
funerals
he also won election to the state
legislature
served as speaker of the house of the
indiana house of representatives
became the first governor in indiana to
serve
eight consecutive years and then served
as u.s
secretary of health and human services
during the reagan administration
otis bowen was known as doc
throughout his adult life and over the
course of his career he found himself
devoting more and more of his time
to public service and less to medicine
once though relatively late in his life
a woman came up to him she reminded him
of the days when much earlier in his
medical career
he had served as coroner of marshall
county
she called to his mind a case he had
been
summoned to one day a middle-aged man
killed in an industrial accident
she reminded him that he had performed
the autopsy
on that man and she told him
that the man on whom he had performed
the autopsy
was her father
otis bowen recalled the event in vivid
detail
describing what had happened and how
deeply
it had touched him and as he talked
tears streamed down his face
in recalling this encounter with the
mortal remains of another human being
i suspect bowen had encountered
his father's mortality his own mortality
the mortality of humankind
bowen had developed personal
relationships with famous people
including u.s presidents vice presidents
speakers of the house senate majority
leaders
he moved easily among the wealthy who
sought to curry the favor
of government officials
he achieved unprecedented political
success in his home state
and assumed responsibility for the
largest department
in the federal government otis bowen was
in short a big deal and his
calls would be taken by the most famous
richest
and powerful people in our country
but what really moved him what brought
him to tears
was not seeing his name on the front
page
or securing a financial windfall
or winning high office what really
touched him
was an encounter with two human beings
one long dead and the other
the decedent's offspring
it was akin to the encounter between
achilles and priam
such encounters are the distinctive
privilege of physicians
who are called upon not merely to
pronounce
death or assign it a cause
but also to witness it
and feel its significance
we adopt disguises we human beings
we load ourselves up with titles
riches authority
yet no matter who one of us happens to
be
or would like respecters of persons
to think that we are underneath
we are all human even the most famous
richest and most powerful people are
made
of the same flesh and blood as the
weakest
the poorest and the most obscure
they too wailed as infants
suckled at their mother's breast
bounced on their father's knee
railed during school years against the
cafeteria food
got butterflies in their stomach on
their first
date debated the care
of aging parents and be far
long found themselves the subject
of debate our costumes
present one reality but to examine us
to know us and to care for us
the physician must allow such layers
to fall away until the unadorned human
being
underneath is revealed the physician's
job is not to
dismiss or condemn the physician's job
is to know and care
much the same could be said for the job
of the poet the philosopher
the theologian consider one of the
greatest novellas
ever penned leo tolstoy's
the death of ivan ilich
in it a successful lawyer and judge
who has devoted his life to moving
up the ladder maintaining a decorous
life and doing what is expected by those
above him he develops a serious illness
as he wrestles with his own mortality he
discovers
that he is not only dying from what i
presume to be
a cancer of the digestive system
he discovers that he has been dying his
whole life
even during his prime because
he has never really lived
in fact he has known less and less of
life's meaning
and purpose with each passing year
the things that brought him pleasure
house
car job title wealth
prestige they no longer bring him
pleasure
and he feels himself caught up in a web
of deception
from which he has no means of
extricating himself
it's not merely that no one will tell
him what he wants to hear
but that no one will utter the truth
you don't want to end up in the position
of ivan ilich who in the last days of
his life
finds himself tortured by a thought
that he cannot get out of its mind
it occurred to ivan ilich that what had
appeared perfectly impossible before
namely that he has not spent his life as
he should have done
might after all be true it occurred to
him that his scarcely perceptible
attempts
to struggle against what was considered
good
by the most highly placed of his
associates
he had immediately suppressed
what he had been looking for
was false his life had been
based on a false premise his
professional duties and the whole
arrangement of his life and of his
family
and all his social and official
interests
might all have been false he tried to
defend those things to himself
and suddenly felt the weakness of what
he was defending
there was nothing to defend
ivan ilich is truly lost he's positioned
himself
at the periphery of the human solar
system
he's been chasing after shiny things
while turning his back on the true
source
of warmth and light his physicians like
him have expunged everything real and
human
from their purely technical practice
and they're not much help they devote
debate diagnoses and treatment regimens
while the human being under their care
withers away
yet they could help they could recognize
that ivan ilich is dying
they could treat him not as a
malfunctioning organ
but as a human being a creature who
regardless of his age
needs someone to be near to talk to
listen
and to care ivan ilitch is a reminder
that the best things in life
are priceless that they are almost never
represented
on resumes or cvs
and that we cannot take them with us
yet we can share them with others
and in so doing not diminish
but actually enrich our own supply
for it is in sharing something
ivan ilich has never done that the
things that really matter
come to life these are the physicians
most precious resources
time to spend where the return on
investment is greatest
attention to devote to the things that
matter most
beauty which lies all around us
if we have eyes to see and ears to hear
truth a glimpse into the way things
really are
and love the capacity to share
a moment or a lifetime with another
person
in grieving or rejoicing with them
ivan ilich is not a protagonist to
admire or emulate
he is a portrait of a human life
misspent
a reminder that even those with their
fingers on the pulse of life itself
physicians and other health
professionals
can become dangerously distracted
from what most deserves our attention
diagnosing prognosing curing
palliating comforting these activities
work in service to a deeper human
reality
one that reveals a glimpse of itself
every time a baby is born
or a person dies we must do our jobs
well
but always mindful of a deeper reality
a thread that ivan ilitch completely
lost
contact with consider another story
a woman with advanced head and neck
cancer
was scheduled to undergo radical surgery
the next day
she had led a life that medic many on
her medical team did not approve of
after the team visited her room and
obtained
her informed consent they prepared to
exit
but before they did so she handed each
one of them a small plastic bag
containing a mustard seed
the members of the team turned and
exited in orders of seniority
as the attending surgeon did so
he dropped the mustard seed in the trash
then the head and neck fellow
followed suit discarding the gift
then the senior surgery resident and so
on right down the line
until the third year medical student the
junior person on the team
left the room but this time instead of
disposing of it
the most junior team member tucked the
little plastic bag
into the pocket of his white coat
his act presents us with questions
what did the patient mean by handing the
members of the team
plastic bags with mustard seeds in them
what did they mean to her and what did
they mean to the team members
and why did the medical student the most
junior person on the team
break ranks and keep
his mustard seed gift
thomas brown the greatest physician
essayist in the english language
knew the answer to that question
in his masterpiece the religion of a
physician
composed in the 17th century
he reminds us of truth that have not
dimmed a lumen
in the long interval since
those centuries saw a lot
since the 17th century in medicine
since then we've seen the discovery or
introduction of blood cells
bacteria the use of citrus fruits to
prevent scurvy
vaccination against smallpox inhalation
anesthesia
the stethoscope antisepsis to prevent
infection the germ theory
x-rays penicillin
blood typing electrocardiography
chemotherapy for cancer the double
helical structure of dna
organ transplantation ct scanners
mri scanners the eradication of smallpox
from the face of the earth
kidney dialysis and vaccination
as a means of preventing cancer wow
there was a lot that thomas brown didn't
know
that we do know and yet thomas brown
glimpsed some eternal truths
that we all too easily lose sight of
consider brown's humanity which is to
say
his charity as expressed in the religion
of a physician
it is a barbarous part of inhumanity
to add unto any afflicted party's
misery or endeavor to multiply
in any man a passion whose single nature
is already above his patience
this was the greatest affliction of job
and those oblique ex-postulations of his
friends
a deeper injury than the downright blows
of the devil it is not the tears of our
own eyes only
but of our friends also that do exhaust
the current of our sorrows which falling
into many streams
run more peaceably and is contented
with a narrower channel it is an act
within the power of charity
to translate a passion out of one breast
into another and to divide a sorrow
almost out of itself
for an affliction like a dimension
may be so divided as if not
indivisible at least to become
insensible now with my friend i desire
not to share or participate
but to engross his sorrows
that by making them mine own i may more
easily discuss them for in mine own
reason
and within myself i can command that
which i cannot entreat without myself
and within the circle of another
the liberal arts don't merely inform the
practice of the physician
thomas brown the physician
thomas brown does not merely draw on the
liberal arts
it would be truer to say that thomas
brown is
a perfection of the liberal arts and it
is through his care of patience
that this perfection has taken place
the first hippocratic injunction is not
merely a rule
that he chooses to follow but a habit
deeply ingrained
in the fibers of his being do
no harm to reach out with compassion to
those who are suffering
has become second nature to him he knows
as he knows that an apple will fall
that he if he shares another's pain the
burden of that pain will be lightened
he is not merely recognizing
acknowledging
classifying forecasting and treating
another's affliction he is encompassing
it
by giving others the opportunity to
share what they usually keep to
themselves
he creates conditions under which trust
can thrive he is finding within the
practice
of an ancient healing art not merely an
opportunity to divert the path of a
disease
but to forge a friendship
brown is most assuredly a physician
a gentleman and a scholar but he is
above all
a human being in full
consider a much more recent portrait of
the physician
as a friend of man that of the
pseudonymous dr
john sassel in john berger
and gene moore's 1967
book a fortunate man sassel practices in
western england's forest of dean
and in many ways he differs sharply from
the people
and the community he cares for he's
different in birthplace socioeconomic
class
educational attainment life experience
sassel knows that in order to care for
his neighbors
he must become one of them and he does
this by building
something there's a castle mode in town
that has long been used as a dump
sassel proposes that they turn it into a
garden
he gets himself named the chair
of the garden committee but he defers to
his neighbors
who know a good deal more than he about
how to design
and build a garden eventually after
years of effort
during which he is labored at their side
most summer evenings
the garden is complete
a neighbor sasso realizes is one with
whom i have labored side by side
working toward a shared vision
not primarily through medical care but
through
shared work he ceases to be merely
for them and lives among them
becoming one of them
cicero famously said if you have a
garden in a library
you have just about everything thomas
brown builds a library
john sassel builds a garden but the
library
is not just a place of instruction and
the garden
is not just a source of nourishing
vegetables
in brown's essays we find objects every
bit as rich and beautiful
as a juicy red tomato
and in sassel's garden lie lessons that
every physician and to a lesser extent
every human being
is called upon to learn in both cases
we must put asunder the things that
should be
separated and meld the things that
should be joined
all in the service of healing of making
whole brown's prose and sassel's garden
teach us the meaning of patience
discipline nurturance
resilience and hope they teach us
that wisdom is not so much propositional
as experiential and that the essential
experience
is to recognize ourselves as part of
something larger
deeper and more enduring
something we can either ignore or
embrace
thwart or cultivate
at some point the most fitting response
is not to beat our breasts
but to bow our heads
to see the connection between the
liberal arts and medicine we can turn to
no
finer recent guide than the greatest
american physician poet
william carlos williams
in a chapter of his autobiography called
the practice
williams shows us that doctoring and
writing
medicine and the liberal arts are twin
aspects of the same calling
of his encounters with patience he
writes
i lost myself myself in the very
properties of their minds
for the moment at least i actually
became
them whoever they should be so that when
i detached myself from them
at the end of a half an hour of intense
concentration
over some illness which was affecting
them
it was as though i were reawakening from
asleep
for the moment i myself did not exist
nothing of myself affected me
as a consequence i came back to myself
as from any other sleep rested
they naively asked how do you do it how
can you carry on an active practice like
that
and at the same time find time to write
you must be super human you must have at
the very least the energy of
two people but they do not grasp
that one occupation complements the
other
that they are two parts of a whole that
it is not
two jobs at all that one rests the man
if the other fatigues him forget
writing it's a trivial matter but day in
and day out
when the inarticulate patient struggles
to lay himself
bare for you or with nothing more than a
boil on his back
is so caught off balance that he reveals
a huge whole community's way of thought
a man is suddenly seized again with a
desire
to speak of the underground stream which
for a moment
has just come up under surface we catch
a glimpse of something from time to time
which shows us that a presence has just
brushed past
us some rare thing just when the smiling
little italian woman
has left us for a moment
we are dazzled what was that
we can't name it we know it never gets
into any recognizable avenue of
expression
men will be long dead before they can
have
so much has ever approached it
whole lives are spent in the tremendous
affairs of daily events
without ever approaching the great
insights i see
every day we begin to see that the
underlying meaning of all they want to
tell us
and have always failed to communicate is
the poem
the poem which their whole lives
are being lived to realize
no one will believe it and it is the
actual words
as we hear them spoken under all
circumstances which contain it it is
actually
there in the life before us
every minute that we are listening a
rarest element
not in our imaginations but there
there in fact it is that
essence which is hidden in the very
words which are going
in at our ears and from which we must
recover
underlying meaning as realistically
as we recover metal out of ore
and here we come to the end
if you care about money
perhaps go into business
if you care about power
perhaps go into politics
if you care about fame become an
entertainer
but if as dostoyevsky puts it
you want not millions but
answers to your questions and especially
if you want to learn to pose even better
questions
if in other words what you want above
all
is the truth
consider a career in the health
professions
the truth lies not in textbooks
or journal articles and certainly
not in the answers to standardized
high-stakes multiple choice test
questions the truth lies in the words of
human beings stripped bare
confronted by life and death ordinary
people
who sometimes quite unknowingly capture
what most needs to be said in words
of unsurpassed beauty
the liberal arts are meant to set us
free
but they do so by means of the true
and to be free we must encounter the
truth
it is perhaps in medicine more than just
about any other calling
that the truth of humankind
is exposed as tolstoy said
we find truth as we purify
gold not by adding to it
but by washing away all
that is not gold
at its best the practice of medicine
represents both the calling and the
consummation
for which the liberal arts have always
yearned
thank you
thank you a question
there are patients within the clinical
siting and you were talking about how
a physician according to thomas brown
how they should encompass
the uh what they are going through in
order to actually like
have a better relationship with that
patient so i was just wondering what can
physicians do
since they have such limited time in
their practice to
really connect with their patients
the 18 seconds is not how long we have
for a clinical encounter with a patient
but the amount of time we listen to a
patient on average
before we interrupt them but the spirit
of your question is bang on
uh the amount of time we have per
patient has been declining
you know maybe an office visit was once
20 minutes
then 15 minutes now 12 minutes what will
it take to shave it down to eight and
it's not just a matter of diminishing
time it's a matter of distraction
because when you encounter a patient
you're encouraged
not only to listen to the patient maybe
not even primarily
to listen to the patient but to be
thinking about things like
an icd-10 code anybody know what an
icd-10 code is
icd-10 stands for the international
classification of diseases
i have to categorize this patient's
complaints symptoms
signs otherwise the visit doesn't count
cpt codes current procedural terminology
that's what counts in health care today
if you want to learn what's most worth
caring about
you need to spend some time in
situations
that draw your attention elsewhere
because it's
only in a deficit of what counts most
that i think we can see most clearly
what really counts for the most
so i come to you not as
an emissary of a profession that is
thriving
in many respects we're at the pinnacle
of the history of medicine you know in
terms of the diagnostic tests we do
the therapies we can prescribe our
understanding of the anatomy
physiology pathology pathophysiology of
human health and disease
we've never risen to this level
but at the very same moment we're at uh
perhaps
unprecedented risk of losing
the human thread in medicine attending
to things
that are secondary at the expense of
those
that are primary so i would encourage
you
if you're contemplating a career in the
health professions
to get as good a liberal education as
you can
and then bring that education as
a form of advocacy beginning day one of
medical school
and carrying right through your
undergraduate medical education
and into residency and fellowship we
desperately need people
who can see what matters most who
realize that not everything
that can be counted really counts and
who realize that some of the things we
spend a lot of time
counting don't really count for much
so never in at least in my lifetime
has the need for liberally educated
people in the health professions been
greater
so that's in a way a call to arms
or at least a call to action you can
actually
not only care for your patients
but you can diagnose and administer
therapy to the profession of medicine
itself
which is not in the best of health in
some respects
but by showing us what medicine looks
like
at its best you can help us reconnect
with the core of medical excellence
thanks again for your question
hi um thank you so much for coming out
to speak to us
for someone who is planning to go into
the medical field and
dealing with patients no matter what
whether it's psychological whether it's
physical
how would you suggest that they best
prepare themselves to face
every patient with the same intention
intentionality
and care as they did the last one is it
can get kind of exhausting to hear again
and again and you're bearing someone
else's burdens
now that's a terrific problem you know
physicians
and health professionals in general can
burn out you know you can only work
so many hours a day only work at a
certain pace
but i think one reason uh that we face
a challenge of burnout in health care
today
is because sometimes we are encouraged
or perhaps
forced to practice in ways that prevent
us
from caring for patients to the best of
our ability
one of the most demoralizing things that
can happen to you
is to have a job you care about deeply
and then be deprived of the opportunity
to do it well
so i don't claim to have a panacea you
know a cure-all that we can administer
in this case
but i can imagine somebody before they
enter the room
with a patient pausing for a few seconds
[Music]
perhaps to offer a prayer perhaps
to reorient and recalibrate
to what this is really all about in the
hustle and bustle
sometimes we can get disoriented i think
that disoriented
disorientation is a big part of people
getting discouraged and exhausted in
medicine
and you can be one of the people none of
us is perfect
there's no foolproof solution but you
can be one of the people who pauses
to recall what this is really all about
before every patient encounter and i
firmly believe that can make a real
difference
not only over the course of a day of
practice
but over the course of a career of
practice
thank you we have time for one more
question
thank you so much for your talk um so
during this time of covid per say there
is a a
greater emphasis on separating the
elderly
from the outside for their um protection
and for their safety
um obviously this contributes to a
greater amount of like loneliness
is there a relationship between um the
sick like the sickness
and lo and loneliness like are we doing
more harm than good by
separating the elderly from um contact
with
uh their loved ones or family that's a
great question
i may have this slightly wrong but
former u.s
surgeon general vivek murthy published a
book i think in 2018
called the epidemic of loneliness he
basically
presented evidence that being lonely
may be about as bad for your health as
smoking 15
cigarettes a day you know that's a
pretty serious
insult to your health i do not
think that captures the damage done by
loneliness
to say it decreases our life expectancy
or increases the number of days
lost from work only scratches the
surface of a much deeper reality but
there
is a recognition that loneliness is bad
for human beings
after the world wars there were large
numbers
of orphans in europe and uh they were
placed in institutions you know their
diapers were changed they were fed
regularly
uh the ambient temperature was right uh
but in many cases
they not only didn't grow and develop
normally but actually withered away
and for a time that syndrome was
referred to
as hospitalism today we call it failure
to thrive
but the lesson there is we human beings
don't just need nutrients
adequate hydration sanitation or hygiene
we also need human contact
by which i mean in part touch we human
beings need to touch
and be touched and because of covid
there are nursing home residents around
the country who at points have been
confined to their rooms for periods of
time
as long as months and you know no
visitors were allowed in the facility
we can do some things with tablet
computers
uh various video conferencing software
but i think there's in the end no
substitute for human
touch and i don't pretend to have
pretend to have a simple solution
but we must make sure when we're
thinking about things like
death rates number of years of lives
lost
that we're also thinking about what life
really means
what it takes to come fully to life at
least to the extent we can
as human beings and i think part of that
is human
contact and that's actually a role that
you could play to some degree
you may know somebody in your family
from your neighborhood
perhaps here in this town perhaps on
this campus who's lonely
and each of us has it within our power
to reach out to one such person you know
and let them know we're thinking about
them
maybe even to schedule a conversation if
possible
perhaps even a visit you do not need a
bachelor's degree
or an md or a residency
certification to reach out to people
to let them know you're thinking about
them
to let them know that you care about
them that's within the
range of competence of every single
person
in this theater and it's it's a
responsibility and an opportunity
i would encourage you to take seriously
if you start doing that now if you go to
nursing school or dental school or
medical school or what have you
you will bring much better habits
habits of perception of understanding
habits of the heart than some of the
rest of us did
you know when we buffed up our gpas
and maxed out our medical college
admission test scores
those things are good but they're not
what matters most
and if you're one of the people who sees
what matters most
and has developed habits of reaching out
to people
to tend what matters most you can make
very significant contributions to the
healing professions
you